Zachary is on the line in Arkansas hey
Zachary
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thanks
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up my wife and I are in baby step
number two we have 87 hundred dollars of
total debt left until we're on to baby
step three we can pay this debt off by
the end of the month how we're going to
do that is we have a tax refund tape
bonus and then we would cashflow the
rest out of our budget with us having
about $7,000 of cash on hand to pay this
off would you hang on to that with
everything going or you know going on
around us or would you just pay off the
debt and be free of that and then move
on to but three to six months emergency
fund really good question
well what we always tell folks is if a
storm is coming or if you've got a time
of serious uncertainty like you're
you're not you're you know aside from
the time we're in now if you're just
your company was doing some layoffs and
you're worried about your job or your
your wife's pregnant got a baby on the
way or anything like that then we don't
do the baby steps we just push pause
play pop push a pause in a time of great
uncertainty and then you would just pile
up cash until the storm goes by whatever
it is and when the storm goes by then
you push play again and you would use
all of that cash down to $1,000 to
become debt-free
beyond that build your emergency fund
beyond that starts your 15% going into
your retirement and so on so you would
just push play again and work the baby
steps straight up with that pile of cash
so you don't really lose any ground that
way now in this current situation the
way I think that would be an individual
determination as to whether you put
press play or whether you just go ahead
and do your plan or you know you keep
you keep going and you knock out the
debt or whether you push pause and use
this money to pile up some cash and that
has everything to do with the stability
of your in
comes in this current environment how
strong are your companies what are your
careers our careers I'm in logistics my
wife is a teacher you know we haven't
been informed that we're going to be
laid off we're both working from home
right now but you just never know what
the next day brings so that's kind of
why we're on the fence part of us wants
to just be free of it at the same time
having you know three to four months
emergency fund kind of buffer right now
would be very peaceful you know
yeah well that means so no one ever
knows about tomorrow on anything by the
way but you know her job but you know
she's gonna get paid right now I don't
know your company what they're going to
end up they may furlough to try to turn
the corner or they might even do some
layoffs to try to turn the corner I
don't know if you get called sideways in
that or not but but you know I think if
you've got some level of fear like that
that that is realistically based and
there may be some that's realistically
based then I'm just going to push pause
and have that pile of cash but don't try
to do both don't sort of do this either
do it or don't based on the probability
of you having a problem the higher the
probability of you having a problem a
mild worry because everyone else is
afraid and freaked out that's not a
reason to push pause I'm looking at the
actual financial condition of my current
company and I'm worried about being laid
off that would be a good reason to push
pause yes sir your wife you can't really
say she's gonna lose her income that's
such a low probability that's just a
vague worry that's just beyond just
being scared because everybody else is
yeah I think hers is a little more
secure I've been laid off before in this
industry I don't have a fear necessarily
but I just think it's easier for me to
be furloughed or laid off yeah I think
it is and the good news is logistics you
just got up I mean supply chain you got
a great career and you'll jump right
back into something but you could have a
really rough month or two that's
possible so I'm with you I'm okay if you
push pause and just pile it up now when
you get when this when the smoke clears
you everybody's back at work you're not
working from home and you
you feel good about the stability of
your place again I wish you wouldn't
taking the job in the first place if you
don't think they were stable so when you
again feel good about the stability of
it that maybe 30 days it might be 60
days then you push play again and you
reach over and pay that stuff off in the
meantime power back caches as you can
pile it okay yes sir we'll push pause I
sure appreciate it thanks for the call
man